there was this video that was
circulating the internet a few weeks ago
about the uh the dink Community the
double income no kids uh there was a Tik
Tock Trend where people are describing
what is life as a dink and why uh why am
I choosing not to have kids why am I
choosing this child-free life I thought
that we could play uh roll that clip of
this one that went viral uh because it's
a good jumping off point to talk a
little bit more about these tradeoffs
and these Choice why people are making
these choices and how much these choices
are actually grounded in the economic
reality so best could you run the dinks
clip for us we go to Trader Joe's and
work out classes on the weekends we're
dinks we get into snobby Hobbies like
skiing and golfing we're dinks we can go
to Florida on a whim we're dinks we're
already planning our european vacation
next year dinks we get a full eight
hours of sleep and sometimes more we're
dinks we get desserts and appetizers at
restaurants we're dinks we can play with
other kids and give them back we're
dinks we still do it three times a week
we're dinks we spend our discretionary
income on $8 latte we're dinks we max
out our 401ks Roth IRA and hsas we're
dinks we don't use our kids or dog as an
excuse to leave a party we just
leave so I I mean my uh reaction to this
initially was like uh first of all it it
is funny and like you know it's okay to
be Dink and and Dink life is fun but I
felt that they were they were kind of
overstating some of the material
sacrifices but what what are your
thoughts on the dink video
Tim well first thing I I would think is
so I'm in a different stage of life than
you guys my oldest is a High School
junior my youngest is seven years old
and my wife my our problem is that our
our social life is too crowded because
through our kids uh friends and and we
have tons of parties and we're again
we're renting now and so we don't you
know host throw parties as much and one
of our kids I overheard somebody said oh
do your parents entertain a lot and one
of my kids said no my my parents are
entertained a lot because we're going to
other people's houses for parties and so
they're a they're comparing themselves
to people um you know with babies and
and very young children and not to
people with with grown children who you
know occasionally are able to get up and
leave um and on the other
hand the idea that maxing out your HSA
is like really something to celebrate
and talk about while on your vacation in
in
Florida that struck me as sort of a very
sad note right there and this is one of
the things that I encountered as I went
around and I talked to people I a big
part of my job has always been what I
call Bar reporting or coffee shop
reporting just talking to strangers and
the great thing about writing a book on
parenting is that everybody has
something to say either they are parents
or they want to be or they've chosen not
to be and one of the the things was the
the sadness the the sort of banality of
the explanations behind why I'm not
going to become a parent a lot of times
it was one woman just said I'd love to
have kids I love spending time with kids
I'd love to have my own but it would it
would weaken my career a little bit and
then if my husband divorced me I I'd be
in a disadvantageous place so basically
it was like unemployment insurance it
was this insurance policy basically why
she was not making this choice and so
just to see some of those things it's
it's uh I mean we've all had bad reasons
for doing things and some of those are
are are pretty sad8 Lockes um is a
pretty sad reason to not have kids yeah
and to your earlier point you know some
of there I feel like there's there are a
lot of economic myths out there uh I
mean housing is one thing that's a
that's a serious impediment I think to a
lot of people having kids and we can
talk about housing a little bit later
but as you note in your book Millennials
have as much wealth as prior generations
and as you go up the wealth ladder to a
point you start having less kids so it's
not so clear that it's just about
economics um and um you know could it be
that some of that mythology just needs
to be punctured the idea that we're like
more strapped than ever and kids are
going to bankrupt
you no absolutely and um Jeremy HP doll
is the is this the numbers guy who's who
constantly does this he just does an
inflation adjusted uh wealth and income
comparing Boomers to Gen X I'm always
grateful that he remembers that we exist
because most commentators don't but
Boomers to Gen X to Millennials at a
given age
and shows that the the wealth is
basically equal across those three and
um affordability of certain of goods
that a family would buy how does that
compare to you know hours of work and he
shows that that is largely stable across
the the last few decades and so the the
affordability thing I keep coming back
to culture I think part of it and uh
Angela rashidi who's my colleague get AI
and Melissa Carney who's at uh Brookings
institution and and University of
Maryland they keep pointing out that
part of the reason that it feels so much
more unaffordable to raise kids and to
some extent is can be less affordable
depending on your life is that fewer
people have a culture that surrounds
them that helps them raise their kids
largely I'm talking about extended
family when my kids were little my
wife's little sisters babies at them now
that my wife's little sisters have
babies it's my oldest that same one who
they were babysitting she's babysitting
her cousins and that's a sort of culture
that's very Pro family that's very
supportive in Israel it's just very
explicit because people are expected to
have kids people are expected to help
other people take care of kids there's
not a mindset of oh your kids were your
choice like buying a boat so it's your
problem and I'm not really I'm not
talking about welfare state policies or
that sort of thing just talking about
cultural expectations you should help
people
raise their kids you should have a
community that's pro- family that
expects people to show up at whatever
you're showing up with kids in tow and
that if if you live in a culture a
subculture that's not familyfriendly you
think I have to pay for everything and
then life does start to become less
affordable yeah I have been thinking
about these themes so much because I
wrote a piece for Barry Weiss's
publication the Free Press um about
being a quote unquote young mom which is
a little bit of a an absurd thing
because because I had my child at 26
right that's not particularly Young by
global standards that's not even
particularly Young by American Standards
uh it's the medi the median age at first
child in the United States for women is
26.3 so like right fully you know very
much the norm however in my millu of
journalists who live in New York City
upper middle class woman college
educated went to like a pretty good
school that whole like subset of
American society this is something where
you know having a kid at 25 or 26 is
very unheard of and there's this
cultural expectation that you'll push it
off until later so the thing that's been
so interesting for me is like you know I
was in this like Park Slope moms group
and it was fascinating to me the things
that the 40-year-old moms because many
of them were legitimately you know 15
years older than me the things that they
think you need to have in place before
having a child and even the physical
Goods that they think you need it it
feels as though we almost have concocted
a sort of absurd sense of how much
having a kid actually costs and surely
if you buy absolutely everything new and
expect to be shelling out $200,000 for
your kid to go to uh you know a an
excellent Elite college and you're
expecting to pay for daycare for every
single year um you know so that you can
maintain your job sure having a kid is
awfully expensive but there are an awful
lot of ways to minimize these things and
to come up with more creative
arrangements to get around all of that
um to me it seems like there's like if
we look at things one way and if we
assume that you know X Y and Z things
must be in place before starting a
family of course it seems unattainable
to an entire generation of of women but
if we rethink what things are necessary
precursors it really
changes absolutely and so I ran uh focus
groups and actually it was the men in my
focus groups who are more likely to say
look the reason I'm not ready and won't
be ready anytime soon to have kids is
because I don't want to just give them
the bare minimum I want to give them the
best of everything I can promise you
guys I do not we do not give our kids
the best of everything we we found a
used piano and it's still Out Of Tune
and they still love playing on it okay
they we send them once we made the
mistake of of travel baseball that's a
whole discussion in the book but
basically we sent them to the local
wreck leagues and and all of that and
the you know they do the basic violin
lessons at school none of them has
gotten good at violin trumpet trumo one
son is good at guitar because he's
interested in girls now but we haven't
given them lessons or or the bests of
everything and that idea that you do
have to give the kids the best
everything that's again not just a cause
but a consequence of smaller families
this idea that I cite in the book of um
well it's good that we're choosing
quality parenting over quantity I argue
it's not good because then it makes
people think you have to give your kids
these really expensive enrichment Etc
the best of everything and then you have
fewer kids and then because you have
fewer kids you invest more in each
that's not necessarily even good for the
kids or the parents if everybody's
constantly anxious that playing the
piano goes from something fun to do
around Christmas with Christmas carols
to being basically a job that's going to
get you your scholarship in a college
nobody's happy or the high quote quality
parenting isn't high quality it's just
more expensive and more anxiety inducing
hey thanks for watching watching that
clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcaster see you
next week